bonsoir à tous bon sens toni morrison
merci évidemment de votre présence je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure vous avez obtenu
le prix nobel de littérature cette année
vous aviez le prix pulitzer en 88 pour
bill offres sont des livres de vous
qu'on trouve en français christian
bourgois votre éditeur est derrière vous
et je crois qu'il faut lui rendre
hommage ainsi qu'un certain nombre de
vos traducteur tels que pierre alliance
il vient une ruée et hors temps chabrier
qui a la foi et votre traductrice et a
été au moment d'une de la maison
d'édition qui s'appelait l'acropole qui
a disparu maintenant l'un de vos
premiers éditeurs et qui ont permis au
public français de rendre accessible
votre oeuvre
quand vous avez eu le prix nobel vous
avez eu une double réaction
vous avez dit d'une part que vous étiez
heureuse que ce prix soit décerné à un
auteur noir américain et en même temps
que vous étiez très heureuse que votre
mère soit encore vivante pour assister à
ce jour là et j'ai eu l'impression que
cette double réaction pouvait être un
résumé de 20 de votre oeuvre dans la
mesure où elle mêle à la fois le destin
singulier d'une famille et en même temps
une cause beaucoup plus générale celle
des noirs américains
klaus à peu près ça avait une
signification tout à fait particulière
comme moi en tant que personne
ça de ma famille et je crois réellement
que ça fait une différence parce que
nous sommes américains
on a senti beaucoup d'autres d'hostilité
parce que aucun afro américains y avait
eu le prix depuis 1932 donc il y avait
un sentiment partagé d'entousiasme et
tout particulièrement également parce
que c'est important que la littérature
afro américaines entrent dans le courant
de l'académisme et 2
du lectorat élargi d'un grand public
mais cette référence à votre mère elle
me fait penser que toujours vos oeuvres
ont ont pris comme une sorte de noyau
dur la famille le drame qui pouvait se
jouer dans les rapports familiaux et que
à travers ce prisme on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure avec peter
sellers parce que sa mise en scène des
perses d'eschyle procède finalement de
la même logique à travers les divisions
d'une famille
c'est finalement l'ensemble d'une
communauté qu'on arrive à dessiner tout
à fait ma mère mon père c'est une
famille qui était à la fois unique et la
fois représentatives et les choses
qu'ils m'ont transmises par l'histoire
par leurs chansons leur dignité
indestructible dans cette oppression
immense
c'est une leçon qui m'a suivi dans toute
ma vie leurs attentes vis-à-vis de moi
était très élevé
les attentes qu'ils avaient vis-à-vis
d'eux-mêmes mais il avait énormément de
rire et de savoir qu'après tout ce temps
que ma mère est encore là et peut
ressentir tout ce que cela signifie cela
a été et bouleversant pour moi tout à
fait bouleversant vous dit volontiers
que vous ne pouvez pas changer l'avenir
comme comme écrivain mais que en
revanche vous pouvez changer le passé
est tout à fait l'avenir est finie
l'avenir ne va pas au delà de la propre
vie de quelqu'un mais le passé sur le
plan de l'imagination est infinie il
faut une révision du passé il faut le
repenser ce n'est jamais concrétisé une
bonne fois pour toutes
c'est comme un puits de richesse de
bijou de puissance de pouvoir de douleur
et le passé est en fait un fini vous
avez le sentiment que votre oeuvre
littéraire peut redonner une mémoire qui
a été occulté refoulé inexistante à la
fois celle des noirs américains et à
l'intérieur même celle des femmes noires
américaines
oui tout à fait
une incidence énorme répression et tout
ça était nécessaire pour passer la suite
on peut pas simplement apprendre le
passé le porter sur son dos cela vous
écrase donc il ya eu une tentative alors
non pas de prêter une grande attention à
ces l'état et mais c'est malheureux
parce que si on ne se souvient pas si on
ne choisit pas et si on ne réécrit pas
son histoire à ce moment là on est
amoindrie en tant que personne et il se
peut qu'on doive refaire cela vous aimez
beaucoup lire vos textes et c'est un
exercice auquel vous vous vous vous
livrez fréquemment comme si finalement
vous vouliez toujours lié à la fois
votre travail d'écriture et puis
peut-être la tradition orale qui a été
la vôtre et donc vous est l'héritière
oui j'entends la langue il y a une
qualité musicale tonale et je ne peux
pas compter sur cela dans un livre dans
un livre il faut que ce soit
parfaitement silencieux parce que
d'autres lecteurs nous entendrons
peut-être pas ce que j'entends moi mais
lorsque je le lis je peux reproduire les
mesures le rythme les sons et accentuer
les métaphores la structure c'est très
important
il ya les pose est ce que ce que l'on ne
dit pas c'est tout aussi important que
ce que l'on dit et ça vous semble
finalement un complément indispensable 7
7 aux réalisations de votre travail
d'écriture et six mois ça semble l'être
mais je ne peux pas compter sur cela
pour un grand nombre de lecteurs
ils peuvent l'autre de façon différente
et pour moi c'est une lutte d'essayer de
reproduire le son de la langue presque
comme si on la jouait en même temps
qu'on en parlait dans ce qui est en fait
un mot silencieux sur une page votre
travail d'écriture en témoigne notamment
le dernier livre qui est paru en
français jazz mail finalement plusieurs
langages plusieurs niveaux de langage
il ya plusieurs types dargaud il ya et
en même temps quelques fois une langue
très savantes comme une partition de
musique et aux au bout d'un moment les
criques
elle même devient une sorte de partition
jazzy est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
de de créer finalement une nouvelle
langue qui soit le métissage des langues
les plus populaires et d'une langue
savante puisque vous êtes par ailleurs
universitaires etc
oui tout à fait je veux puiser dans
toute la gamme au niveau de langue en
anglais lyrique biblique langage de la
rue langage standard et que ça semble
être du tout afin qu'on ne soit pas
limitée par la quelconque de ces niveaux
de langue et que l'on se déplace comme
l'a fait ma famille comme l'ont fait les
noirs dans quartier d'où je venais qui
sont montés et ont descendu dans
l'échelle est improvisé la langue la
casse est pour livrer quelque chose qui
était une troisième chose qui était une
longue était vraiment la leur et pas
simplement les reproductions de la
langue du maître plusieurs de vos livres
partent d'un fait divers
c'était vrai de be love c'est vrai de
jazz aussi est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que le fait divers dans sa
banalité dans son ancrage dans le
quotidien a une portée sociale et
politique immédiate
nous vivons dans un pays extrêmement
violent
nous sommes complètement armes et les
états unis et pour des afro américains
c'est comme une guerre qui se poursuit
depuis 300 ans avec des hauts et de bas
et la violence perpétrée ne peut pas
être ignorée on ne peut pas dire ça ne
s'est jamais passé où ça n'aurait pas dû
se passer donc introduire la violence
est important pour la vraisemblance mais
ce qui est encore plus important c'est
que ces personnes ont non seulement
survécu à ce genre d'agression elles ont
été créées créative et au triomphe et
culturellement sur le plan du style et
moralement mieux et c'est cela la beauté
qui consiste à mettre en sandwich la
violence et le triomphe parce que ces
personnes ne se seront jamais autorisé
être simplement les victimes de la
violence dans une enquête que notre
confrère libération avait fait il ya
quelques années
pourquoi écrivez-vous vous aviez répondu
j'écris pour créer de l'ordre de la
beauté de la vie à partir de ce qui
m'entoure et qui n'est que chaos misère
est mort c'est toujours votre programme
littéraire
c'était bon on n'est ce pas en fait je
n'ai pas le choix je ne peux pas ne pas
écrire je suis très effrayé dans ce
monde et je ne me sens pas cohérente ou
même raisonnable lorsque je n'ai pas un
projet d'écriture
donc je pense que dans un sens c'est
toujours ce que je veux faire créer
l'ordre à partir d'un désordre complet
et pour des raisons purement
personnelles et j'espère également bien
sûr que cela signifiera quelque chose
sur le plan esthétique et sur le plan de
l'ordre social pour les autres aussi
comment comment conciliez-vous le fait
d'être même à votre corps défendant un
écrivain qui est un emblème d'une
communauté celle des noirs américains
celle des femmes noires américaines
et puis là la dimension d'universalité à
laquelle vous êtes en droit d'aspirer en
tant qu'écrivain est ce que c'est une
contradiction est ce que c'est une
contradiction fertile est ce que c'est
un conflit douloureux je ne connais pas
d'écrivains qui n'écrivent pas
spécifiquement sur sa propre culture sur
sa propre texture si j'essayais d'écrire
comme un écrivain universel ce serait de
l'eau ce ne serait pas un livre mais je
partage le même terrain que tous les
autres écrivains c'est à dire que je
suis très détaillé et spécifique sur les
personnages les émotions la région et
j'espère que mon écriture est
suffisamment bonne pour que cela établit
une connexion pas parce que ça a été
fait mais c'est en dehors mais parce que
c'est à l'intérieur
vous avez tout en étant ancré dans cet
art go noir américain etc
vous avez fait un détour par le grec
ancien vous dites que la tragédie
grecque vous a souvent inspiré on on le
voit d'ailleurs dans une sorte de
résurgence du personnage de m'aider et
c'est de la tragédie grecque jusqu'à la
rythmique même de la dette de la grèce
antique
alors est ce que c'est pour vous un
modèle
notamment sur la question du destin qui
traverse la vie des individus la grèce
antique
j'ai beaucoup étudié la littérature
grecques en tant que l'étudiante et elle
me semblait très africaniste dans un
sens la notion du coeur de la danse le
personnage paradigmatique les
conséquences d'une activité unique qui
ressemble au destin mais qui est de la
responsabilité de l'individu
tous ces shows toutes ces choses là ont
participé à ma partition perception du
monde et cela ressort vous avez raison
dans mon oeuvre
mais pour moi ce n'est pas étranger pour
moi c'est très familier et ce n'est pas
une contradiction entre la vie d'un
afro-américain et la vie d'un grec pour
moi c'est intimement reconnaissable
[Musique]